you know there's been a lot of reports
out there I can't say I agree with all
of them certainly but I support this guy
you know I think that's what needs to be
said I don't know what anybody's writing
or what anybody thinks but is this foot
injury wasn't his fault
you know this was a total accident as it
was really wasn't his fault
and it's in a serious injury I know some
people are smart and at it but it's
really not a laughing matter
the guys is was hurt he was innocent he
didn't do anything wrong
and the helmet thing is a personal
matter to help you know he has a strong
feeling about what he's worn on his head
and we're supporting John Gurdon from
Saturday night after the preseason game
against the Rams supporting Antonio
Brown because he really has no choice
but to support him despite the frozen
feet
despite the refusal to wear one of the
approved helmets and the insistence on
wearing an outdated helmet that can no
longer be certified that has inspired
today's draft yes it's here craziest
off-field storylines in NFL history
nothing crazy about the coin toss
because it's rigged Krista's gonna call
tails and he's gonna win go ahead I
already have it figured out go ahead
yeah by field tails today I'm on fire
let's keep it going it's a it's a tails
day go ahead what do you got okay I mean
I I don't you know I hate to go down
like Negative Nancy Ville here okay with
all negative stuff so but the crazy ones
are mostly negative so there aren't many
crazy good stories exactly right so the
Michael Vick dogfighting I think has got
to lead the list for me all right I mean
and and not only because of the
craziness of the whole situation and the
improper nests and the foul play and I
as an animal lover hate to see
everything that happens certainly I mean
I got dogs myself and all that but what
makes it even crazier is that this
happened at a time when Michael Vick was
arguably the most famous most electric
player in the NFL unlike anything we had
ever seen I mean we're sitting here
raving about Kyler Murray and things
he's done and Baker Mayfield
we never saw anything like Michael Vick
gotten veiled to the
NFL now he did his time he's you know
he's learned from his mistake and moved
on and I'm a big fan of my don't a
mistake yeah it was a six year lifestyle
was dogfighting a criminal activity that
would have continued but for the fact
that it was detected it was not a
mistake that's the one thing that gets
me fired up it was a mistake it was a
corrupt and criminal lifestyle and cruel
and now that I have a dog oh boy if I
had a dog back in 2007 I thought I was
rough on Mike Vick then and uh and I
didn't own a dog and I didn't love a dog
the way I loved my des my guy would have
driven down to Virginia and I'd have
found Mike Vick it is time and he's done
a lot of good things since then so
you're right I'm wrong and saying it was
a mistake it was just an horrible act by
him and friends and whatever else it was
just horrible all but there's nothing I
could say there's no excuse for Michael
Vick me fired up yeah he didn't do all
the time he should have done because the
prosecutor in Surry County Virginia that
was hell-bent on letting this guy get
away with all of it when the opportunity
came to get him indicted on cruelty to
animal charges which were separate and
apart from the federal charges that he
ultimately pleaded guilty to and he
could have gone to jail for a long time
for killing dogs that he deemed or unfit
to fight drowning electrocution remember
all that yeah did not go to prison for
that he should have been indicted he
should have been convicted he should
have been imprisoned in Virginia we're
not retrying the guy again okay we're
just going the craziest on this off I'm
just telling you if you're trying to say
he paid his debt to society I'm saying
there's an unpaid debt in Virginia that
was never that was never me this is why
I was scared of the strapped with you
Negative Nancy I knew you can't how I
just speak in truth bro I'm just sorry
go ahead got the guy the guy chose to
use his millions on a corrupt and
criminal enterprise and involved abject
and total cruelty to animals he deserves
all the criticism he gets in the thing
that bothers me we act like it never
happened now I hey it's Mike Vick he's
doing this he's doing that forget about
it the guy forget about it I'm done with
that alright let me move on to something
that is is also negative but a lot
funnier than dogfighting the love
how was that not your first choice there
was nothing crazier than the love about
2005 by week excursion on Lake
Minnetonka multiple Vikings players
decide it would be a good idea to rent a
boat and also fly in some prostitutes it
just kind of went from there and that
and that's all I'm gonna say the talk
now and say everything I want to say
about the Love Boat
go ahead there was a lot of love going
on in a Love Boat actually love yeah but
all right maybe it was lust you're right
I think we go lust okay I mean gosh I
just feel horrible about even bringing
this Aaron Hernandez that's the crazy
one of the craziest things ever okay yes
a star player for the greatest franchise
in the NFL right now gets accused and of
course is found guilty and convicted of
murdering someone you know again I hate
to even talk about this stuff again it
kind of giving me chills through the
spines here and I know Aaron Hernandez
is no longer with us but still the fact
that Aaron Hernandez was such a integral
part of that New England Patriot team
very liked and respected with the team
super talented I mean he is part of this
new breed of Titan that we see now Aaron
Hernandez was before his time he was one
of the first of his kind this tight end
slash slot receiver slash you can put
him at running back sometimes he can do
all these different things but
Gronkowski Hernandez the Patriots how do
you stop the Patriots too tight on set
he has these this issue and you know
it's just something you don't expect to
happen in the New England Patriots and
it was just a crazy story from a guy who
had a crazy upbringing there's no excuse
for what he did he certainly was lost in
his own mind and in the world in general
but that's got to be one of the craziest
ones I've ever seen yeah I mean I
remember you know over the years when
you do this and you're working on these
stories every day the things that just
stop you in your tracks and and and
become the centerpiece
of everything that you are writing about
and and it becomes all-consuming and
there's there's 50 different angles and
it doesn't go away anytime soon and I
think the fact that you know these
stories that linger for days weeks and
months and that have consequences that
go well beyond the events those are the
ones that fall into the category of the
craziest stories and and so I have to
stay in that category Chris I have to go
Ray Rice right and it's not just the
knockout punch the horrendous
inexcusable act
it's everything that came after it it
almost took down a commissioner for
crying out loud because of the question
of whether or not the NFL had the video
of that of that incident yes at the time
that he was initially suspended only two
games did they have the video did they
lie about the video there was a good
10-day period where I think the
commissioner's tenure was up in the air
there was enough pushback and I think
there were owners who are like why do we
I remember the argument why do we need
to subject ourselves to this we can find
somebody else to do what the
Commissioner does we don't need somebody
who's going to be the lightning rod for
this kind of controversy and I mean it
was something that lasted for weeks and
then it influenced the way the NFL
implements its personal conduct policy
and even now the NFL takes a harder line
on domestic violence especially when it
involves a female then than they ever
did before
all because of Ray Rice you're right
yeah I mean and and out of the fact I
mean he was the running back for he was
a top-tier running back in the NFL for a
top-tier team in the NFL as well all of
it was crazy and you're right to this
day even with any incident we have now I
think our mind always goes back to Ray
Rice and it was there video along with
it that's all we ever think of even with
Ezekiel Elliott and the Vegas incident
or Kareem hunt all those things I think
it always draws us back to Ray Rice so
I'm with you there that was a crazy one
- can't disagree all right my last one
here I got to go with Colin Kaepernick I
mean come on I don't you know off the
field the kneeling but where it led off
- off the field was unlike anything I
think we've seen in the history of
professional sports okay this probably
would have been my first pick but I
figured you might gloss over it and I
could keep it to number three be
is it really off field uh well I don't I
mean it happened on he died Oh literally
when it's still there on the building
well okay it happened off the field and
but what happened off the field after
that is he literally wasn't allowed on
the field anymore cuz of what he did
just on the edge of the field and we've
never ever had to become such a
political issue and a president chiming
in about not hiring a guy or not signing
him or you know calling him a bum or
whatever it may be that I think is what
makes it just the crazy to me you know
let alone the circumstances and the
backlash and everything that went along
with it but the way the president got
involved took it to a whole new another
stratosphere to where it literally
became not a Kaepernick thing and became
an NFL thing and it caught fire
throughout our whole country and became
polarizing so I got to keep that that's
got to be in my draft yeah it was late
August 2 2016 when he first began to
kneel during the national anthem other
players followed suit and it was a year
later that it all really reached full
boil with the president getting involved
and meetings between owners and players
and some unfortunate comments that were
made and and it's still look it's still
lingering now and Colin Kaepernick is
still being I believe improperly frozen
out and I I think that I think that that
this is the last year if he doesn't get
a chance this year it's never gonna
happen and I think there's a chance if
the XFL gobbles up guys who get cut in
two weeks in five days when they reduced
the rosters of 53 if third string and
fourth ring quarterbacks get signed by
the XFL that pushes Kaepernick higher up
on the list of guys who potentially
could be called by NFL team so I feel
like it's now this year or it's never
all right one more and and this one is
funny for everyone but the guy who did
it and Chris I'm surprised you didn't
consider this one because chances are
you may have owned this device at some
point in time if you were trying to beat
a drug test
Onterrio Smith remember him draft pick
of the Vikings death about 15 years ago
or so his inator came into the NFL with
a little bit of a history of some
positive marijuana tests and look we're
on the record we don't think any of that
should matter they shouldn't invade
these guys private lives but still the
rules are the rules and Ontario Smith
had a device for beating the rules and
it was found in his luggage at an
airport and it turned out it was a
prosthetic device aimed at allowing him
to supply it with clean sample so that
he could you know I into a cup or in if
you're in riding in the backseat of the
Chris Sims Peter King car from Cleveland
to Pittsburgh either way to provide a
clean sample and the wizard aider
entered the lexicon and the guys who
actually founded the company they ended
up going to I don't know they went to
jail but they got arrested they got
charged because a lot of these drug
tests are done for federal employees who
have safety-sensitive jobs that this
this is something that was being put out
there to help people essentially break
the law so there you can unless you
bottle whizzing there's like the shut
air advantage it's discontinued baby
it's gone how do they do that how do
they how do they put somebody in jail
for that honestly I'm amazed they sold
them they were they it was illegal to
manufacture and sell these things
because it was subverting federal law by
allowing FAA employees other employees
who are regulated by federal agencies
that say I can't have certain
percentages of alcohol or drugs in your
system what is this they're they've
created a device that allowed people to
break the law what I've always wanted to
is like what did what why did TSA get
him in trouble into this thing - that's
what it always amazed me like oh we have
an unidentified fake penis in someone's
luggage we need to get the security out
here in two seconds like how does that
become even a thing that's where I was
always amazed by that either way I do
remember that was a funny story yes it
was puck technology the two founders
pleaded guilty in Pittsburgh federal
court to a count of conspiracy to
defraud the government one count of
conspiracy to sell drug paraphernalia
and they were sentenced to six one guy
was sentenced to six months in prison
the other guy got three years of
probation so there are consequences
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports